hello everyone I do hope you enjoyed my
Q&A video and congratulations to
everyone who was able to watch it until
the end you are an excellent viewer and
another good news it's now available in
1 ATP so I have no idea what's wrong
with YouTube why is it only available in
360p when I upload it that's already my
second video this week that has this
problem and also it wasn't available on
iOS but that's all taken care of now so
let's return to the 1959 candidates
tournament and here we have a very
interesting game between Bobby Fischer
and Paul Karras now before I forget I
managed to find one photo of the two of
them playing in this tournament it's not
from this game because every player
plays four times against every other
player as you can see Karras has the
white pieces in this game but you know
oh it's also a very nice photo it really
shows you the ambient that was used and
here you can see pal Benko enjoying the
view over the board but I couldn't find
any other photos of two of them playing
on this tournament so let's get back to
this game and it's also very interesting
as Fischer does have the white pieces he
opens with E 4 and we have C 6 as
Fischer already said that so it's only
countered him with C 6 but that's
because the Soviets knew that Fischer
was really struggling with C 6 with the
caro-kann defense in his younger days
and since Chris was strictly an e5
player him using a move like c6 he
really thinks that Fischer will repeat
the positions he had against miss love
and Petros and in previous rounds which
he does Knight c3 by Fischer we have d5
Knight to f3 and now Bishop to g4 we
have h3 Bishop captures Queen captures
and Knight to f6 and here we have D 3 d3
is a move Fischer employed in his
younger days against the caro-kann later
in life he began playing d4 but even
later in life he got back to d3 but
after moves east 6 which was played in
this game g3 instead of this g3 move
later he played this variation
a three not allowing black to play this
Bishop to b4 but there is but even later
in life around 1970 there was a really
famous match USSR versus the rest of the
world where Fischer crushed Tigran
Petrosian
where Petrosyan employed the caro-kann
against him but he went immediately for
the exchange of variation and really
really crushed the iron tiger so that
that might be a nice game to show
perhaps after this one so g3 in this
game Bishop to b4 now developing the
bishop inning the knight the bishop to
d2 and now d4 Knight back to b1 we have
Queen to b6 defending the bishop and b3
now we have a 5 a 3 and here carries
returns at Bishop to e7 and here as you
can see if you're having the white
pieces you're not really having the the
greatest of days your Bishop is on d2
not very reactive it's not that easy to
develop the bishop okay you can go e 2g
to but it's not gonna be very active
this night and b1 doesn't really have
anywhere to go the pawn is nicely
blocking it the c3 square it can be
developed to d2 the bishop is there so
it's gonna be a problem for a Fisher to
develop his pieces
Bishop to g2 now a 4 we have B 4 and now
Knight B to d7 as a favor played before
now this night will support this point
to be pushed to c5 castles we have c5
now and rook to a - roof - a - is a very
nice idea by Fischer but Karis doesn't
go for it
the idea is that if black tries to win
material here by playing C capture some
before let's say C capture something for
a capture some before and now tries to
grab the pawn it's important to see that
a rook to be - actually pretty much wins
the game for white but it doesn't win
the piece immediately Black has 95
attacking the Queen and after the Queen
moves now comes Knight to c6 defending
the bishop so now after you capture it
and now Knight captures now we play
Knight a Queen to d2 again with a double
attack on this night on before but now
black has a three this was also you know
you also have to take this into
consideration and after rook captures
Sun before now Queen to a5 preparing to
push the pawn
- adieu and now the movie had to find
was beat rook to b3 and after 8 - now
Queen captures on 85 threatening Queen
captures rook na 8 so if you grab the
night and promote the Queen first white
ball capture your rook with check and
only then recapture the Queen so as to
rook captures now night a3 and now white
is up a piece and winning the game so a
lot of things to take into consideration
after the Fischer played this rook to e8
- but Karis isn't really bothered by
this
he plays castles we have B captures on
c5 Bishop captures on c5 and Queen to d2
Fischer is preparing to push the pawns
first of all pawn to f4 and then
depending on what carries plays he filed
by Karis and now f4 immediately rook F
to c8 we have h4 rook to c6 and Bishop
to h3 Queen to c7 now F captures on e5
Knight captures on e5 and Bishop to a
for pinning that night and here Bishop
to d6 was played
we have h5 r up to 85 and rook 25 is
witted the idea of bringing the rook all
the way to the Kings side to help out
with the defenses and you know a threat
and white position so we have h6 trying
to break open the Kings side we have
Knight to g6 and now Queen to f3 rook to
h5 and here Fischer really really
doesn't have a good move your Bishop is
attacked on h3 if you try something like
Bishop to f5 then you get Bishop
captures on f/4g captures and rook
captures on h6 and with all of these
active pieces Kara says it's gonna be
it's gonna be a very easy win for him a
fish Rose Knight is still undeveloped on
b1 the rook is awkwardly placed on a 2
so it would be an easy game so after H
rook to h5 Fischer tried Bishop to g4
attacking the rook but now carries
simply plays Knight captures on f4 and
here you have a problem do you capture
the night or do you capture the rook
official decided to capture the broken
but even if you play G captors on f4 you
get Knight captures on g4 and after
Queen characters simply rook captures on
h6 and
you can again see that it's all over
Fischer still has these two undeveloped
pieces of rock to g6 is a terrible
threat if you stop it then you get real
cancerous and c2 rook after screen
captures
now there's the threat of Queen to H to
checkmate
if you block this then you get rook
Bishop check King h1 no better for check
King do you want and Bishop to d3 check
and the White King has nowhere to go you
have to block this and now white can win
this game however black can win this
game however he pleases you can capture
the rook Queen captures now rook h1
check rook h2 check and you win the
Queen and the game
so after this Knight to f4 move Fischer
decided to play Bishop captures on h5
Karis played Knight captures and now
Karis has two pieces a knight and a
bishop for a rook and you know I might
and a bishop against the rook isn't
always decisive but look at again
Fischer's pieces here hg after Sun g7
was played now Queen to d7 going for
that h3 square Fischer blocks this and
now Knight to g4 and here Fischer has to
develop somehow he can't continue
playing with all of his pieces like that
he plays Knight to be 2 but here after
Karis played night to the e3 check here
official resigned the game his king is
in check the rook is forked but even
after he moves Karis doesn't even have
to grab the look he can simply play
Knight captures on g3 and the Fischer
doesn't really have any moves rook F 2
now comes Bishop to g5 preparing maybe
rook g6 Rock h6 Knight to c4 Knight
captures captures and now rook to f6 and
it's all over
Queen g2 now rope to h6 threatening rope
to h1 again if you block this it's a
rock h1 check you have to give up the
Queen if you play King g2 you get Queen
to h3 checkmate
so this is just one of the variations
that allows black to win this game
nicely but yeah after Knight to b3
Fischer resigned at the game and a nice
victory for pork heiress who I already
mentioned it in in my previous videos
from this tournament in the end got
second place in 1959 candidates
tournament won
point behind Michael towel so yeah I do
hope you enjoyed this it's a it's one of
the one of fishers earlier attempts to
counter the caro-kann defense and yeah
it might be nice to show how he played
it later in life like I mentioned in
that game in nineteen seventy USSR
against the world where he crushes the
iron tiger so yeah I would like to thank
Fred Ackerman for a contribution to my
channel thank a lot to really appreciate
it as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you all for watching
and I will see you soon and we can look
at this photo one more time before this
video ends it's a very nice photo so
yeah thank you all and I will see you
soon